if you want super springy legs amazing
balance and supreme athleticism then you
should train with the hindu squat if you
want to avoid injuring your knees be
able to squat down with your
grandchildren in old age then you should
train with a hindu squat and if you want
to unlock some incredible benefits for
your aerobic capacity even your focus
endurance and willpower then you should
train with the hindu squat
in fact the question we really need to
ask is why aren't more people using this
amazing exercise i have some theories
about that actually but we'll get to
that in a moment first let me try and
sell you on this incredible movement
but let's start by answering a question
that's arguably pretty fundamental to
this whole topic and that is what is a
hindu squat so essentially a hindi squat
is like a regular squat apart from one
major difference that being that you're
going to come up on the balls of your
feet when you get to the bottom of the
movement and this actually changes the
effect that the hindu squat has in a lot
of different ways that's not the only
difference there is a specific hand
movement that we're going to talk about
in a moment there's a specific breathing
pattern which can add so much value to
this exercise but the fundamental
concept behind this is that we're doing
a squat and we're coming up on the balls
of the feet so why come up on your toes
well of course first of all if you count
more on your toes during a squat
that's going to place more emphasis on
your quads this is really good if you're
interested in hypertrophy and you want
to get that nice teardrop look which i
do i could certainly use a little bit
more aesthetics in the legs area this is
also great for athletic performance
because as ben patrick and his other
toes guy talks about a lot when you
bring the knees over the toes this is a
great way to target the vmo the vastus
medialis in particular this is the thigh
muscle with the highest density of fast
twitch muscle fiber which means it's
great for explosive movements like
sprinting jumping really high and you
don't really target this at all during a
regular squat so that's a fantastic
reason to be getting yourself into this
position it's also a great way to
strengthen the tendons this is also
really important for athletic
performance because of course the
tendons are stronger than muscles and
have those nice elastic properties which
are great for rebounding sprinting
jumping landing at the same time this
can help to prevent injury you have an
existing knee problem then going
straight into hindi squats might be a
bit too much for it but if you do
partial rep ranges if you gently ease
into this movement it's really nice
gently to start moving the knee past the
toe once again to strengthen those
tendons so they're fortified against
those positions in future then you run
and jump you don't really bend at the
legs all that much you hardly bend at
the ankles instead you're translating
force off of the ball of your foot this
position is far more similar to the
position you'll find your foot during a
hindu squat oh wait look there's some
cool stuff on the floor here
wait a second did you just see that that
was a hindu squat so i'm trying to
demonstrate here in a particularly goofy
manner is that when you squat down to
pick something up off the ground to
enter a low cupboard the way you
normally squat is on the balls of your
toes you perform a hindu squat in other
words this is a really important
everyday movement pattern and if you
want to make sure that you can play with
your grandkids and you can move
healthily and normally into old age then
strengthen those knee tendons with this
exercise is a fantastic way to do that
and especially if you build up to it
slowly with lots of nice progressions at
the same time this is going to
incorporate a balanced component because
you've got to come up on the balls of
your toes which is harder than you might
imagine and at the same time you're
strengthening your feet because in that
position it also engages the calves a
lot more than a regular squat so for all
these reasons this is definitely a
movement that i think everyone can
benefit from
you know what else everyone can benefit
from skin care
teech hanley is a company that provides
skincare products for men and it makes
life more simple by providing you with
all the different products you could
need for a complete skincare regime and
you get an instruction card that shows
you how to use each item when to use
each item and it makes the whole thing
as straightforward as possible that's
great if you're anything like me and you
have very little interest in anything
that doesn't involve running and
explosions that said it has become a
nice part of my routine the products do
feel very rejuvenating and i do like
just how straightforward and simple they
make everything
so for example you could start with
their level one system and that comes
with all the basics that's a daily face
wash to get rid of the dirt and grime on
your skin a two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of dead
skin cells an am moisturizer with spf 20
because you should always be protecting
your skin from the sun and a pm
moisturizer to help your skin stay
hydrated and healthy throughout the
night
and i've got over five thousand five
star reviews so yeah they must be doing
something right
and if you become a member you'll get
loads of benefits including twenty
percent of the retail price the ability
to customize your box exclusive monthly
deals and the ability to pause and
cancel at any time there's free us
shipping and low cost shipping to most
other countries and because tiege hanley
is sponsoring today's video they're
offering a great deal just click the
first link in the description
and you'll get 30 off your first box
plus a free gift seriously that's an
amazing deal click that link and get
started today
so let's talk about something else how
do we actually perform this movement
when in terms of the basic squat itself
like i say all you're doing is you're
doing a regular squat you're coming up
on your toes at the end now you can opt
to stay on your toes throughout the
whole movement or you can just raise up
on your toes as you get to the bottom of
the movement either way is fine you
don't have your feet about shoulder
width apart facing mostly forwards but
it's not the end of the world if they do
turn out slightly and then you're going
to drop down so you're not controlling
descent in a big way but at the same
time you don't already bounce off of the
bottom position so as far as the arms
are going what you're going to do is at
the top of the movement you can have
your arms out in front of you then
you're going to roll your arms back then
you're going to go into an extension
like you're reaching into your back
pocket check out original strength for a
great tutorial on how to do this and
then as you squat down you're going to
bring your arms forward you can try and
brush your feet or brush the floor but
you don't have to swing them up and then
bring your arms up as you move back
upwards and this is going to provide a
little bit of momentum to help you move
upwards again and if this still seems
counterintuitive then the way to think
about this is that's the way you would
jump if you're doing a broad jump say
you're going to jump forwards you'll
probably swing your arms back then swing
them forwards as you left forwards and
this is a great way to coordinate that
upper body and lower body so you're
moving the whole body as one unit at the
same time this is just going to burn
more calories get the blood circulating
more and it's going to teach you how to
move like that so that when you do come
to jump you're better at producing more
force from that lower position with your
whole body not just your legs
what's really interesting though is the
breathing aspect and this is interesting
because it might be the reverse of what
you're used to doing so if you were to
perform a regular squat you would
probably breathe in to create that
intra-abdominal pressure that's going to
help support your core and your spine
then you'd squat down and on the way
back up you'd release you'd breathe
outwards during the actual contraction
this is a typical way to breathe and
it's called biomechanical breathing
however during a hindu squat you're
going to do something called anatomical
breathing or anatomical match breathing
and here you're going to be breathing
out as you go down and up as you come up
and the reason for this is that you're
going to be doing what comes naturally
to the body to the lungs because as you
squat down in the hindu squat you're
compressing your core you're compressing
you're bringing your knees up you're
getting smaller this is going to push
your diaphragm up and expel air as
though you're a pump and then when you
stand back up you're expanding you're
opening up the rib cage and you can
breathe back in almost comes naturally
this makes it a much more relaxed form
of breathing that's less tiring than
contracting and tensing and breathing in
that air and then releasing it in a
controlled manner and this allows you to
perform higher rep ranges whilst
remaining relaxed and this can translate
to greater work capacity across the
board i've seen so many people talk
about this reverse breathing pattern and
say that's really good and interesting
but i hadn't seen anyone on youtube
actually explain why this is useful and
so that's where i thought there was
probably room for one more video on
hindu squats on youtube i do try not to
just make videos for the sheer sake of
it nasal breathing is also encouraged
i'm just keeping your mouth closed
breathing through the nose this cleans
the air as it comes in increases nitric
oxide and it can strengthen your
respiratory muscles over time this will
again greatly increase your work
capacity your cardio performance
and finally should also be doing
diaphragmatic breathing that means your
stomach should move first if you place
your hand on your stomach you want to
relax there so this then allows the
diaphragm to drop filling up the lungs
from the bottom upwards as much as they
can and the chest should move second as
the oxygen eventually fills up to there
like i said guys there are loads of
variations whether you want to make it
easier or more difficult if you want to
make it easier then obviously a really
simple way to do this is just use a
partial range of motion that means
you're not going all the way down just
go as far as you can do comfortably and
never train through pain alternatively
you can hold on to something use it as
an anchor that could be a chair that
could be a railing or in this case a
wooden post in the middle of the woods
of course if you do have existing knee
pain then don't just jump into this i
highly recommend speaking to someone who
can check you over in person first that
said gentle exercise around the area is
much better than complete bed rest
if you want to make things more
difficult on the other hand then there
are plenty of options of course you can
perform a one-legged version of this
movement so like a pistol hindu squat
this is actually a bit easier than the
regular history squats it's less of a
mobility challenge you can perform kind
of floats down the bottom and balance
and test out your range of motion great
way to improve your balance your ankle
strength etc another alternative that's
not a variation of the hindu squat but
performs many of the same functions is
the [ __ ] squat this is a hindu squat
except you're going to lean back much
further thereby creating a lever arm and
increasing the amount of pressure on the
knees this is also a massive balance
challenge though you can of course put a
hand on something to balance on your way
down this is not for beginners
categorically same with the pistol hindu
squat but if you can face it and build
up to it slowly this is a fantastic way
to build up massive quads i've seen
people get huge quads from just this
exercise alone and it translates to
fantastic athletic performance quick
disclaimer i'm really sorry if i butcher
any pronunciations here often you'll
hear the hindu squad referred to as
bitac however bytak is a more generic
term for the squad the purnam by attack
or full squat is performed with the
heels on the ground as you might be used
to you still use the arm movement and
the breathing the bell hawaii by attack
or wrestling squat is performed on the
balls of the feet but often with a
little jump at the top check out karate
tv for a much better demonstration of
this move
there's no reason that you can't combine
the hindi squat with a jump this is
going to help you to build more
explosive power you can also perform
little bunny hops at the bottom of the
movement as many as you like this is
another variation of the pelhawani by
tak again apologies if i'm pronouncing
this wrong however you can just add as
many bunny hops as you like bunny hops
are fantastic for building that
springiness that bounciness in the knees
at the bottom of that position
so if all that's true and hindu squad
provides so many benefits then why is it
that more people aren't doing it well my
theory is that it's not easy to pile on
loads of weight and the allure of
lifting huge amounts of weight is simply
too great for most people traditionally
the hindi squats performed by indian
wrestlers and they would perform high
high repetitions it was about
conditioning it was about strengthening
those knee tendons preventing injuries
and becoming more explosive there are
lots of benefits to performing low
resistance high repetition i've talked
about that loads of times on this
channel so i'm not going to go into it
in great detail here now but suffice to
say that not only does this build
strength endurance so that you can keep
on going but also increases blood supply
to those tendons which naturally get
less blood supply so this is great to
strengthen them and prevent injury in
the knees this can also boost your
myonucleic account to increase your
chances of building more muscle and
maintaining that muscle helps to recover
faster and at the same time if you're
going to failure then you might get some
strength benefits from this as well and
there are plenty of people who can
attest to the power of high high
repetition hindi squats and the great
thing is you can do this then anywhere
and if you look at the position of your
heels in the hindi squat and they're
slightly elevated as though you're on
squat blocks this makes it much easier
to get into that deep deep position
without worrying about things like butt
wink without worrying about back pain or
bending over falling backwards and by
the way guys if you do want to see a
training program that incorporates this
kind of movement and tons of others
selected for their functional benefits
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program and video course super
functional training 2.0 the pro team
performance system that's a training
program designed to improve every aspect
of your performance it also comes with
over two hours of instructional video an
80 plus page ebook and much more so put
a link to that in the description down
below check it out if you like
thanks a ton for watching this one guys
i hope you found it useful and
interesting let me know in the
description down below what exercise
you'd like to see me tackle next time if
you're interested in squatting then you
might also enjoy my video on deep squats
and why they're so beneficial i should
use them every single day that should be
popping up right about now alternatively
subscribe and hit the notification
button that helps me out hugely and at
the same time it'll make sure that you
don't miss any of my future content more
along these lines either way thank you
so much for watching this one guys and
i'll see you next time bye for now
you